da haben viele kopf fische vögel und
südlich die punkte eigentlich verwandte
wo käse front wo in erster weltkrieg 30
menschen gestorben sind
das ist luftlinie 30 km vor der schweiz
von basel
[Musik]
einmal anfangen mir mitglieds traf um zu
erfahren was die und europa verstehen
daher suche ich mir dort macht er
feststellt dass es viel lob geht die
rede immer für europa als sieht das
anders ich eine eigene fischer 36 hat er
sieht man in europa xxi und das hätte
nicht als witz gemeint
der norweger sagt er sei noch nie in
europa gewesen
obwohl norwegen natürlich teil des
kontinents europa ist was also ist
europa und sie gehört dazu ist europa
eine verheißung eine notwendigkeit eine
bröckelnde fassade dies meine fragen
heute schon sind sie dabei
meine beiden gäste sind ausgewiesene
experten wenn es um europa geht die
politikwissenschaftlerin ulrike gero sie
ist professorin an der donau universität
krems und gründerin des european
demokratie land und frank schimmelfennig
er ist professor für europäische politik
und der eth zürich schon sind sie da
herzlich willkommen avg rom seit monaten
führt jetzt das tauziehen um einen
geregelten braig sieht die presse
man hat dem projekt verschoben auf
halloween glauben sich wird noch zu
einer lösung kommen
ich glaube keiner hat eine kristallkugel
und das ist wirklich schwierig ja also
wir sehen ja eigentlich dass man gar
nicht mehr austreten kann das
offensichtlich die eu nicht europa aber
die eu so ein vertrags geflecht ist und
so viele wirtschaftliche zusammenhänge
hat das ist ganz schwierig ist
auszutreten ja das haben wir ja erlebt
aber zurück zu ihrem norwegischen
fischer vielleicht ist europa einfach
ein sehnsuchtsort ja und dieser
sehnsuchtsort korreliert natürlich nicht
mit der eu die wir haben und das ist das
spannungsverhältnis was wir hier auf dem
kontinent diskutieren für viele in
großbritannien offenbar gerade kein
sehnsucht sorgen deswegen sagen sie
dieses spannungsfeld ja herr
schimmelpfennig ist sie haben ja im
interview meter zeit dass ich sie
interessant fand kürzlich gesagt dass
ein exit eines landes eigentlich keine
politische handlungsoptionen mehr sein
sollte er trägt die eu keine weiteren
abtrünnigen das war damals in der euro
krise da ging es da
um das der deutsche finanzminister
wolfgang schäuble griechenland aus dem
euro aus der euro zone heraus drängen
wollte
das hat nicht funktioniert ich glaube
hier gibt es deutliche parallelen
zwischen dem dreck zieht auf der einen
seite und dem brett auf der anderen
seite es zeigt sich doch wie stark diese
diese bindungswirkung europas ist es ist
eben sehr kompliziert und sehr riskant
staaten auszuschließen ist es aber auch
sehr riskant und sehr kompliziert aus
diesem gebilde auszutreten
ich habe gerade ein bisschen forschung
gemacht und auf der eine zahl ja auf der
skala von 0 bis 10
wenn man die bürger fragt wie findest du
die eu ja sind die europäischen
bürgerinnen in ihrer gesamtheit ziemlich
genau bei 5,1 das ist fünf ist zu gut um
auszutreten ja aber zu schlecht um sich
wohlzufühlen ja und ich glaube das ist
die debatte wir stehen wirklich auf
messers schneide
die usb fünf nummer eins auf der skala
von 5 bis 10
und interessanterweise ist das ja auch
dann bei den abstimmungen oft so dass
die hälfte remane und die andere hälfte
exit also genau man hat sozusagen
wirklich diese spannung auch noch
innerhalb der bevölkerung eine absage
europa polarisiert sehr stark aber es
zeigt sich dann eben in solchen
verhandlungen wenn es spitz auf knopf
steht wenn es um dabei bleiben oder
herausgehen gc zeigt sich dann doch dass
es das eben sehr starke zwänge einfach
auch gibt es ist ja europa braucht ja
nicht nur darauf dass es eine dass es
eine starke zustimmung der bürger gibt
sondern dass sich einfach eine
wirtschaftliche politische verflechtung
etabliert hat der mann sich erst bewusst
wird ja wenn man versucht auszudrücken
und es zeigt aber eben auch das
runde visp schimmelpfennig gesagt hat im
grunde gespaltene gesellschaft haben
also zurück zu meiner skala 5,1 das
heißt tatsächlich dass die eu als
solches natürlich politische meinung ist
spaltet und das sehen wir ja eigentlich
in allen mitgliedstaaten also wer sind
denn jetzt heute die briten sind das die
remake oder die bag sind hier ist ja wer
sind die franzosen makro oder marine le
pen wer sind die deutschen pfalz of
europe oder peggy da und wir sehen dass
die frage wie hältst du es mit europa im
grunde die politischen meinungen in
allen europäischen ländern spaltet auch
in italien und so weiter und das ist das
politische problem die politische
gretchenfrage wie hältst du es mit
europa entsprechen die heute in dieser
sternstunde philosophie nicht nur über
europa wegen des drecks sieht sondern
auch wegen der anstehenden europa-
parlaments waren die nächste woche
beginnen
es ist so dass großbritannien daher auch
teilnehmen muss die ganze weise und man
spricht oft von einer richtungswahl im
moment was ist anders an diesen
europaparlaments waren jetzt im
vergleich zu vorherigen man muss
natürlich sehen dass das dass die rede
von der richtungswahl auch dazu dient
die bürgerinnen und bürger zu
mobilisieren
ich glaube gar nicht dass die wahl so
ganz anders ist als es die letzte 2040
war also was wir sehen werden ist dass
die dass die rechten nationalistischen
kräfte noch etwas mehr zulauf bekommen
wir werden sehen dass die dass die frage
wie hältst du es mit europa mehr noch
zur kernfrage wird mehr wichtiger ist
als bist du links bis rechts und es wird
auch dieses mal darum gehen die
wahlbeteiligung oder den rückgang der
wahlbeteiligung zu stopfen und
vielleicht etwas mehr wahlbeteiligungen
zu haben und es geht um die rolle des
paten des europäischen parlaments im
gefüge der institutionen dass es vor
allem die frage gelingt es dem
europäischen parlament wieder den den
spitzenkandidaten auch zum
kommissionspräsident zu machen ich würde
trotzdem ein geständiger sprechen wollen
ich glaube schon dass die wahl in zwei
punkten signifikant unterschiedlich ist
von dem was wir 2014 erlebt haben das
eine ist wer hat eine sehr niedrige
wahlbeteiligung 2015 bleiben 42 prozent
europaweit und wir haben jetzt
schätzungen dass zum beispiel in
deutschland 69 prozent zur wahl gehen
ich war vorgestern im
59 prozent der polen dass wir die
doppelte wahlbeteiligung für polen bei
diesen europawahlen das zeigt schon dass
wir eine andere spannung im system haben
also das ist irgendwie schon diesmal um
was geht und dass die meisten bürger
verstanden haben es geht wirklich um
sehr viel das war ihre frage
richtungswahl ja das zweite was ich als
signifikanten unterschied sehr zur wahl
2014 ist dass wir tatsächlich eine ganz
enorme bürger mobilisierung haben die eu
kommission gibt ja wahnsinnig viel geld
aus jede stiftung jede universität macht
im moment irgend einem vortrag zu europa
jedes theater jahren sind diese
geschäfte die leute diskutieren also ja
eben im rathaus europa europa europa und
wir adressieren die bürger europa die
bürgerinnen und bürger europas zu diesen
und in diesem jahr zum ersten mal direkt
erinnern sie sich an den brief den makro
verfasst hat und deren ein zeitungen
gestanden ist da hat makro ja nicht
geschrieben liebe frau merkel lieber
heute lieber herkunft können wir mal ein
bisschen mehr integration machen sondern
er hat ja adressiert lizzy tarieren
situation so ruppen das heißt die bürger
und bürgerinnen europas bekommen diesmal
eine direkte ansprache und da scheint
mir schon ein paradigmenwechsel darin zu
liegen auch welches politische projekt
wir verhandeln wir verhandeln nicht mehr
die vereinigten staaten die da irgendwas
integrieren sondern wir verhandeln
bürger die ihre souveränität in einem
gestaltungs projekt europa auf diesem
kontinent suchen
jetzt haben sie vorhin von einem
sehnsuchtsort europa gesprochen
mir kam in diesem zusammenhang auch noch
der französische philosoph bernard lévy
in den sinn der wahl gesagt hat europa
ist kein ort europa ist eine idee sie
nicken
ja das stimmt alle versuche europa als
ort irgendwie festzumachen sind
eigentlich immer gescheitert es ging
immer darum wie sich europa definiert ja
und vor allen dingen auch wie es sich im
gegensatz zu anderen definiert das zieht
sich durch die geschichte das fängt an
mit damit dass sich europa als gegensatz
zum orientalischen despotismus definiert
hat dann im mittelalter christentum
gegen islam dann liberale demokratie
wiederum gegen autokratie kommunismus
und auch heute
da demokratie eigentlich kein
alleinstellungsmerkmal von europa ist ja
versucht es sich eben sehr stark über
die über die gemeinsamen institutionen
zu definieren also der berner aurélie
macht ja gerade auch dieses theaterstück
ja dass er in verschiedenen europäischen
bühnen und einfach selbst inszeniert wo
er sich auf die bühne setzt und im
grunde zwei stunden so wie ich das
gehört habe ich hab's noch nicht gesehen
aber relativ frei einfach mal durch die
europäische geistes und literatur welt
wandert um die ästhetik also die die die
literarische die republik europäern die
geistes ist tätig europa sichtbar zu
machen ja insofern ist natürlich europa
eine idee und welche idee ich glaube
tatsächlich europa ist die idee von
beidem und das hat natürlich eine akute
politische bedeutung heute wenn wir zum
beispiel auch über geflüchtete reden
aber natürlich ist europa die idee von
flucht und von grenzenlosigkeit ja weil
natürlich ist europa wir schulden den
namen jener politischen prozess in die
heute so ungefähr auf dem gebiet von
syrien leben würde ja und die auf einem
stier auf nach europa gekommen ist also
im prinzip geflohen ist mit sei es ja
hier gelandet ist und diesem kontinent
den namen gegeben hat ja und insofern
ist natürlich europa das was wir heute
tatsächlich aktuell in politischen
debatten machen nämlich das was man in
den sozialwissenschaften als er ihn
nennt also sozusagen in dem ich ein
sehnsuchtsort besucher nicht mit dem
anderen zu verbinden und über den
anderen zu definieren das heißt europa
die identität entsteht natürlich in der
abgrenzung von den anderen ort und der
immer in der überwindung von grenzen und
ich glaube da ist ganz viel zu holen von
dieser metaphysischen bedeutung der
europa also der frau europa und dem was
für heute diskutieren ist europa ein ort
müssen wir ihn schützen müssen wir
frontex machen wie offen muss europa
seien definieren wir uns über
geschlossene grenzen oder über offene
grenzen
das sind ja hochaktuell und strittig
diskutierte politische fragen wobei
natürlich europa skeptiker sagen würden
dass die europa von zeus als stier aus
ihrer heimat entführt wurde
ja ich würde
doch zugleich sehr nervös hat sich ja
verkleiden müsste es war ja ein alter
stier der auch noch gestunken hat und
der sich der schönen jungen prinzessin
nur nähern konnte weil er vorher wie es
heißt seien gegessen hat um überhaupt
ihr nahe zu kommen zu können
aber was wie was ich denn interessant an
der idee wenn sie gestohlen wurde für
die europaskeptiker naja das europa und
das ist ja das narrativ dieser
europaskeptiker dass eben diese
europäische idee den menschen ihre ihre
ihre wurzeln nimmt ihre wurzeln die eben
in der in der heimat in der nacht in der
nation liegen und dass das in dem sinne
eben europa als idee eine gewisse
entführung ist er aus dem was das was
was das angestammte politische milieu
darüber werden wir auf jeden fall auch
noch sprechen die rolle des
nationalstaates die sie zum beispiel ja
sehr skeptisch sehen heute ich würde
gerne noch ein schritt zurück gehen wir
haben diesen norweger sprechen gehört
also wenn wir über europa sprechen
da spreche ich aus schweizerin zum
beispiel ja auch über einen kontinent
sehr oft aber ist wenn man über europa
spricht immer gleich die eu auf dem
tisch wir sprechen ja zum beispiel oft
nicht von den europaparlamentswahlen
sondern nur von den europawahlen und in
diesem kontext kann man ja mal die frage
stellen gehört sagen nicht europäische
union zwingend zu europa dazu na ja
offensichtlich nicht also wenn wir
angefangen haben mit dem fischer und dem
sehnsuchtsort und der fischer europa als
sehen sie besucht hat oder die praxis
diskussion diskutiert haben dann scheint
mir das spannungsverhältnis ja
tatsächlich zu sein dass viele leute auf
diesem kontinent das können wir über uns
auch empirisch messen ja die meisten
leute hier in europa sind irgendwie für
europa wir wollen ein offenes
demokratisches tolerantes europa ja das
ist da gibt es zwei drittel mehrheiten
dabei wollen wir die eu das ist eine
ganz andere frage
und auch der politische protest den wir
jetzt bei den sogenannten identitäten
oder populistischen und
nationalistischen parteien sehen
er richtet sich nur gegen die eu nicht
gegen europa also gucken sich an salvini
der vor zehn tagen in mailand eine
pressekonferenz macht und mit den wahren
finnen usw
da sitzt der sagt ja nicht ich bin gegen
europa er sagt nur diese ist nicht gut
für meine italiener
das ist was ganz anderes aber ich denke
schon dass wir heute europa nicht mehr
ohne die europäische union denken können
ich meine es ist ein zeichen des
erfolges der europäischen union das wenn
man europa sagt im grunde automatisch
die europäische union mitdenkt und ich
glaube es ist auch ein merkmal das
europa von allen anderen weltregionen
unterscheidet ja dass wir hier so eine
starke supranationale gemeinschaft haben
ja und dass man sich daran reibt ja ist
auch ein zeichen dafür dass europa auch
durch die europäische union definiert
wird und selbst die staaten die nicht
dabei sind sind doch in irgendeiner form
alle dabei norwegen ist im binnenmarkt
mit dabei die schweiz hat ihren hat ihre
bilateralen verträge mit der ist mit der
eu es gibt eigentlich kein land was wir
gemeinhin als europäisch verstehen das
nicht in einem engen institutionellen
verhältnis mit der mit der europäischen
union steht sie haben das stichwort
genau zur nationalen institutionen da
sind wir natürlich auch bei der frage
wie begann das alles eigentlich und ich
würde gerne bevor wir über die zukunft
ideen für europa sprechen war kurz in
die geschichte schauen ganz nach udo
marquardt zukunft braucht herkunft wir
springen zurück ins jahr 1957 in rom war
wurde die gründung der ewg der
europäischen wirtschaftsgemeinschaft
eingeladen
[Musik]
frankreich deutschland die benelux
länder und italien wollten den kern
eines von nationalismus freien
europäischen großstadt es schaffen der
ein gegengewicht zum ostblock bieten
sollte
[Musik]
das risiko dass diese staatsmänner
eingingen schien beträchtlich sie banden
ihre länder laut vertragstext für alle
zeiten aneinander
sie waren zu opfern bereit im glauben
das nur dadurch wohlstand und frieden in
europa gesichert würden
die ewg war zu verhandlungen mit den
anderen europäischen ländern bereit um
eine große europäische freihandelszone
zu schaffen
die bemühungen scheiterten aber die idee
der freihandelszone legte weiter sieben
europäische länder england schweden
dänemark norwegen österreich portugal
und die schweiz entschlossen sich diese
weniger intensive form der
zusammenarbeit als die ewg sie versprach
zu verwirklichen im januar 1960 wurde in
stockholm der efta vertrag unterzeichnet
man einigte sich die zölle auf industrie
waren untereinander abzuschaffen um den
handel auszuweiten um einen produzenten
und verbraucher macht zu schaffen
der 100 millionen menschen einschließt
ja wir sehen also es gab immer schon
unterschiedliche bemühungen
zusammenzuarbeiten auf jeden fall von
vornherein auch zwei solche
supranationalen institutionen
ich habe hier noch einmal die karten auf
denen man das ganz schön sieht 19 57
gründung der ewg in rot die länder die
dazu gehört haben und dann 1960 deswegen
samaná die schweizer auch am tisch mit
unterzeichnen
eben die efta dafür die schweiz heute
auch noch mit dazu
der europäische freihandels vereinigung
und wenn man die karten jetzt
übereinander legt sieht man die eu und
die esta also die ewige ist in die eu
übergegangen um wir sehen im dunkel pink
die länder die zur efta gehören und in
helleren pink die eben was das jahr
zeigt ist dass es immer schon dieses
sogenannte europa der zwei
geschwindigkeiten gegeben hat also
diejenigen die gesagt haben so genannte
turbo euros wir wollen voran wir wollen
möglichst schnell möglichst viel
zusammen arbeiten und diejenigen die
eher skeptisch sind und gesagt haben ein
bisschen wirtschaftlich zusammenarbeiten
zelle abbauen war gut seien vielmehr
wollen
wobei es glaube ich ein schiefes bild
ist zu sagen dass es europa der zwei
geschwindigkeiten wert weil das ja heißt
okay wir haben das gleiche ziel wir
kommen nur in unterschiedlichen
zeiträumen dort an ich glaube die die
zentrale unterscheidung zwischen dem fk
modell und dem neben dem ewg modell ist
ist tatsächlich das ziel und sind dies
sind die mittel also die fh ist
entstanden durch staaten die sich mit
dem ziel einer supranationalen
gemeinschaft eben nicht anfreunden
konnten sondern die souveränität bei den
staaten belassen wollten und nur nur ein
freihandelsabkommen abgeschlossen hatten
das nie das ziel hatte ja tatsächlich in
einer in einer union in eine super
nationale gemeinschaft überführt zu
werden
da kann man vielleicht auch noch die
ironie der geschichte mit reinbringen es
gibt am pikantes detail nämlich dass die
großbritannien ja bei der ewg damals
nicht mitmachen wollte sie haben gesagt
sie wollten die labour-regierung sie
wollten keinen sozialistischen projekt
beitreten und haben damals eigentlich
die efta angeregt also dass die eu ein
sozialistisches projekt oder ewg damals
gewesen
da kann man heute gesamte sogar schon
historische kommission dg in steyr
christian korte also eher sagen dass die
entscheidenden leute die die feder
geführt haben bei den vertrags geben von
den römischen verträgen das ist heute
glaube ich stellt auf die art der
europäischen sozialwissenschaft und
politikwissenschaften
das waren schon eher ich sag mal
kabarettistische subsidiäre christliche
soziale marktwirtschaft gedanken güter
aber es war ein konservatives
gedankengut was eine christliche
unterfütterung hatte aber mit
sozialismus er nichts zu tun hat ich
glaube das kann man einfach mal zu sagen
also da haben sich die briten vertan
aber was mir wichtig ist wenn wir diese
unterscheidung beleuchten wollen ja ewig
eu nur wirtschaft oder ein bisschen mehr
das sagt er ja herr chernick ja ich
glaube dass man wenn man das
soziologisch betrachtet ist das ja ganz
schwierig weil wirtschaft wird ja von
menschen gemacht und das was damit
passiert mit solchen integrationsprozess
und deswegen haben wir ja damals auch
immer von der neo funktionalen methode
gesprochen das heißt diejenigen die sich
in einen gemeinsamen wirtschaftsprozess
begeben müssen nachher auch ein bisschen
politik drum herum machen warum
weil menschen wird von wirtschaft
getragen sie könne nicht sagen dass die
wirtschaft die politik ja hier ist der
export da sind ist die demokratie
sondern das gehört schon einfach
zusammen und das ist ja genau das
problem was wir heute diskutieren wir
haben ja immer geglaubt oder die briten
zum beispiel haben geglaubt wir können
es nur wirtschaft wir sehen aber dass
wir jetzt 5 millionen europäer auf den
britischen kontinent haben die nicht
wissen was wird aus ihrer
sozialversicherung wir sehen dass wir
fünf millionen briten in europa haben
die auch nicht wissen was wird aus ihren
landhäusern im ardèche dh die wirtschaft
ist ja nichts abstraktes sie ist
getragen von menschen man kann es ja
vielleicht noch einfacher sagen man kann
sagen eine wg die eine gemeinsame
haushaltskasse habt legt geld zusammen
das ist sozusagen die idee auch einer
währungsunion der euro und da muss man
sich natürlich auch überlegen wie gibt
man dieses geld gemeinsam aus die
wirtschaft man damit und sie schafft man
ausgleichen wenn jemand plötzlich kein
geld mehr hat und da aber es ist noch
ich finde es auch noch mal interessant
eben genau diesen öfter ewg was wir
heute eu zu beleuchten weil das glaube
ich vieles aus sagt darüber wie wie die
europäische union sind sich entwickelt
die öfter war im grunde ja wenige jahre
nach ihrer gründung im grunde schon fast
wieder geschichte weil sich
großbritannien entschieden hat der ewg
beizutreten hat das war 1961 frankreich
hat das noch ein paar jahre verhindert
aber was ist es was es eben auch
deutlich macht die briten haben sicher
nicht für die ewg entschieden weil sie
auf einmal doch von diesem europa
gedanken beseelt gewesen wären sondern
weil sie gemerkt haben
da entsteht ein wirtschaftliches
powerhouse und wir können es uns
wirtschaftlich nicht leisten dort aussen
vor zu stehen und dass das ist auch die
eigentliche erklärung dafür dass die
meisten der damaligen elfter starten
heute in der eu sind nicht weil sie auf
einmal diese idee so toll fanden sondern
weil sie die wirtschaftlichen chancen
gesehen haben und die gefahren wenn sie
außen vor bleiben ich würde gern noch
mal ein bisschen weg von diesem der euro
die umverteilung und wir teilen das geld
irgendwie zusammen auf ja also es ist
glaube ich immer wichtig noch einmal in
solchen diskussionen zu sagen wenn wir
von einem eu budget heute reden reden
wir von 0,9 prozent des europäischen
bruttoinlandsproduktes also genau von
war
60 jahre sind ganz große geld ist ganz
woanders ja wovon ich reden wollte ist
wirtschaft und was macht eine währung
eine gemeinsame die macht was mit den
menschen
es ist ja was in europa in den letzten
20 jahren entstanden dadurch dass wir
den euro hatten also wenn sie heute von
hamburg nach neapel fliegen ja und mit
dem gleichen geld er in der tasche sind
können sie ja auch sozusagen prozesse
der vergesellschaftung beobachtung wir
haben uns ja aneinander angeglichen wir
haben unsere verhaltens cody und
restaurants allüren unsere kleidungs
geschichten unsere supermärkte das hat
sich ja alles angeglichen
das heißt die währung ist ja ein
soziales produkt was eben auch für
gesellschafts prozesse hervor bringen
und das ist mir viel wichtiger dass wir
diesen prozess verstehen als das unter
das ist nämlich dann was anderes als zu
sagen dies nur wirtschaft also wenn wir
auf diesen prozess der
vergesellschaftung der durch geld zum
beispiel hervorgebracht wird schauen
dann sind wir bei anderen fragen als nur
transferunion würde sie gern
interessant ist ja dass in den
maastricht verträgen damals also die
gründungsverträge der eu sozusagen die
sprachen ja von dieser klausel junien
also diese idee dass man tatsächlich
immer mehr zusammenwächst zu seiner
super nationalen einheit
die frage ist natürlich jetzt wie wir
das genau verstehen aber klar war
eigentlich damals ja schon dass das
nicht nur ein wirtschaftsraum sein so
oder ja absolut
ein absolut aber es ist glaube ich zwei
zwei teile dieses begriffs der ja auch
sehr umstritten ist nicht mal das eine
ist monieren ja ja ich glaube in den
deutschen verträgen heißt es
zusammenschluss der der völker was eben
auch heißt union ist nicht gleich staat
ja dass das das ziel einer einer einer
einer staatsgründung eines bundesstaates
ist in diesem begriff nicht drin und das
andere ist das effektiver kloster was
einen prozess meint also das heißt die
idee war jetzt nicht durch einen
einmaligen großen gründungsakt hier den
europäischen staates oder bundesstaat zu
schaffen sondern in kleinen schritten
immer weiter zusammenzuwachsen von unten
graduell diese union immer enger zu
machen ja es ist dieser europäische
union definiert sich vielmehr über den
prozess an siemens
wieso aber das ist ja genau das problem
weil wir den prozess jahr aufgehört
haben ja also wir haben ja seit ungefähr
also mindestens mal zehn jahren und der
euro krise überhaupt nicht mehr daran
gedacht wie wir das irgendwie noch
einmal vertiefen verbessern und in
diesem prozess gehen sondern wir sehen
seit mindestens einer dekade absolute
des integrations tendenzen keinen
politischen willen mehr daran was zu tun
also ich bin ja ganz bei ihnen in der
analyse und in der tat mit der
fragestellung ja aber er war klose
junien hieß ich habe keine 90er jahren
für kataloge arbeitet das hieß damals
ganz klar wir haben einen markt wir
haben eine währung wir wollen eine
demokratie wir haben das damals
politische union genannt wir haben
gesagt wir können nicht nur eine währung
machen wir brauchen eine haushaltsunion
eine fiskalunion eine sozialunion
halo hat schon 1989 die europäische
sozialcharta verabschiedet wir haben
jahrzehnte oder dass die dekade der 90er
jahre von der politischen union
gesprochen
oder vielleicht maximal auch von der
europäischen wirtschaftsregierung ja da
kommt regierung schon rein aber es ging
immer darum dass wir eine gemeinsame
europäische demokratie gestalten und ich
finde schon dass man sagen kann dass wir
die ambition auf diese gestaltung die
haben wir seit mindestens eine dekade
aus den augen verloren ja was natürlich
auch mit den ursprüngen zusammenhängt
ich meine das war damals bei doch
natürlich eine sehr technokratisch
vision also dieses europa gewissermaßen
von oben zu schaffen indem man durch
verträge durch entsprechende
organisationen dieses europa
zusammenbringen und ich glaube ein teil
der probleme die wir die wir heute haben
ist dass diese dass diese
technokratische vision eben von von von
oben kam und nicht ausreichend
unterstützung von um den hals oder
stellt sich auch die frage was ist die
rolle der nationalstaaten in den
nationalstaaten wohnen ungern ihre macht
wirklich abgeben und ein stück weit
müsse es dazu ja kommen ja aber da würde
ich erst mal wie in der analyse spricht
widersprechen ja der leerstand ja nicht
da und hat gesagt ich mach jetzt europa
von oben weil ich gerade mal irgendwie
frieden schaffen will oder soja sondern
wir müssen ja mal verstehen dass das was
wir gemacht haben und heute als
erfolgsprojekte auf dem europäischen
kontinent verhandeln nämlich den markt
und die währung ja das hatte ja ganz
starke ökonomische treiber das waren
doch die industrie die in den neunziger
in den 80er jahren gesagt haben moment
mal wir brauchen mal ein binnenmarkt
cheney report 5 millionen arbeitsplätze
es waren die industrievertreter die dann
zu dior gegangen sind und gesagt haben
kannst
eine europäische einheitliche akte
machen damit wir den binnenmarkt machen
dann hat mir 1992 den binnenmarkt machen
den maastrichter vertrag und guess what
dann kommen die banken und sagen oh
wunderschön jetzt habe man gemeinsam mag
dann packen wir doch mal eine
europäische währung drauf weil ist ja
blöden gemeinsam markt zu haben
und dann haben wir da schilling ist co
und und und lehrer und keine ahnung was
und dann hatten wir noch mal einen
riesengroßen ökonomischen treiber weil
die banken gesagt haben wir wollen jetzt
den wegfall der transaktionskosten und
jetzt sagen ich oder ich was heißt ich
sage aber jetzt glaube ich sind wir in
der situation dass jetzt die bürger
sagen moment mal jetzt haben mag jetzt
haben eine währung und wir bürger wo
sind wir eigentlich ja kriegen wir jetzt
auch was und das ist ja jetzt die frage
die wir jetzt bei diesen europawahlen
diskutieren wortes info citizens was ist
da eigentlich drin für die bürger ist es
nur ein projekt was markttreiber hatte
oder wo die banken der treiber war und
können wir souveränität der bürger und
was die bürger wollen auch anders
verhandeln
aber wenn ich ihnen zuhöre ich hatte am
anfang diesen begriff gebracht des
europas der zwei geschwindigkeiten wo
sie gesagt haben das ist nicht der
richtige begriff was geht hier überhaupt
nicht um tempiwechsel oder um
unterschiedliche einschätzungen eines
tempus sondern es geht nur darum welche
vision oder welchen sehnsuchtsort hat
man aber man kann ja trotzdem sagen wenn
ich ihnen zuhöre das scheint so ein
bisschen zu sein wie eine entwicklung
man hat man angefangen und so geht es
jetzt voran man hat auch versprechen
gegeben
klasse junior und jetzt ist das sowie
naturgewalt die müssen doch schon ein
bisschen steuern aber das wird in diese
richtung gehen und da kann man schon
sagen unterschiedliche tempi
unterschiedliche vorstellungen wie
schnell das zb gehen soll
das sieht man ja schon und da gibt's ja
nicht nur jetzt unterschiedliche
bewegungen zwischen den ländern sondern
auch innerhalb der länder
die sehen ja zb dass viele städte also
urbane regionen wo die die
globalisierung vielleicht sich stärker
auch niederschlägt wo musik kulturelle
zentren entstehen da sind sehr viele
leute begeistert von europa
währenddessen in ländlichen gebieten wo
menschen sich tendenziell eher abgehängt
fühlen skepsis aufkommt die wollen
bremsen
also ich gebe ihnen recht dass wir
spannungs prozesse haben in allen
europäischen gesellschaften die können
wir auch messen und diese spaltung
prozesse haben sehr viel zu tun mit
metropolregionen und mit oralen also
ländlichen strukturschwachen regionen ja
das ist die eine spaltung und die läuft
quer durch alle länder also wir können
heute nicht mehr sagen die deutschen
sind europäisch oder die franzosen sind
nicht oder die finnen sind europäischen
die portugiesen sind nicht das macht
keinen sinn mehr ja
die weisen stadt land graben zur stadt
land graben aber auch andere spaltung
entlang identitaire linien also zum
beispiel dieser wertekonsens also
abtreibung homosexuelle und diese ganzen
geschichten die führen natürlich gerade
auch im ost west verhältnis das können
wir messen zur spaltung heute in den
gesellschaften
was mir aber wichtig ist ist dass wir
wir haben es eben schon mal kurz
angesprochen dass wir in diesem
wahlkampf zum ersten mal glaube ich eine
unglaublich starke akzentuierung des
begriffes des bürgers haben european
citizen das ist wirklich überall im
moment und wenn sie das hat ja was also
es gibt ja auch so eine österreichische
band die heißt bilderbuchs oder rock
band ja mit ihrem böhmermann das ist so
ein deutscher comedian die haben jetzt
im vorfeld des europa wahlkampfes
einfach mal europäischen pass gemacht ja
und was heißt ein pass ein pass ist
natürlich eine imago für und staat also
wenn sie ein pass wollen brauchen sie
den staat und das kommt drauf zurück was
der schimmelpfennig eben gesagt hat
dieses ever closer junien sie haben eben
gesagt da war nie die absicht dass wir
dann mal statt draus machen da bin ich
dabei das war nie die absicht ja der
punkt ist nur dass wir heute
offensichtlich ein desiderat haben
können wir nicht noch ein paar ganz klar
klartext sprechen sie wollen ja einen
raschen starb aber sie wollen eine
republik draus machen das ist ihr
vorschlag frage sie haben hier zum
beispiel der neue bürgerkrieg da hat das
angefangen die idee aber auch ihrem
europa eine republik werden muss jetzt
kommt ein neues buch das ist ihre idee
eine republik und zwar eine republik
aller vorbild usa mit einem gewählten
präsidenten einen relativ umfassende
idee eines sozialstaates könnte man doch
sagen den sie da gerne etablieren wollen
also ich fange mal an mit max weber der
in den vorlesungen vor der deutschen
gesellschaft für soziologie 1912 eine
relativ interessante definition gemacht
hat was ist die nation aus dem kopf
zitiert hat er gesagt
kann man doch als nation letztlich nur
eine gruppe von menschen bezeichnen die
aus einer gefühlsebene heraus
beschließen zusammen einen staat zu
gründen
ja und ich habe versucht mal diese
definition anzuwenden auf das was heute
in europa passiert also wenn wir uns
angucken dass wir in europa wahlkampf
haben wo die bürger immer nennt da sind
wenn wir uns angucken das wir
statistiken haben wo auf die frage
fühlen sie sich eher europäisch oder
ihre nationalität sind übrigens führen
die ungarn ja die ungarn fühlen sich zu
60 prozent eher europäisch als ihrer
nationalität zugehörig wie auch immer
wir haben klare datenlage dass dieses
europäische gefühl einfach wächst bei
den europäischen bürgerinnen und bürger
wir haben debatten über einen
europäischen mindestlohn über eine
europäische arbeitslosenversicherung wie
auch immer und man könnte ja jetzt mal
wenn man von dieser definition von max
weber ausgeht und dann noch den pass von
jan böhmermann nimmt und sagt davor dann
doch offensichtlich europäische bürger
ein pass also eigentlich einen
europäischen staates und ich will das
nun mal in die debatte werfen also ich
will gar nicht apodiktisch sagen das
wollen wir das müssen wir das passiert
ist das ist nicht meine sache aber zu
sagen können wir den prozess in dem wir
sind analysieren als einen state
building prozess in europa
sie sind skeptisch ich bin skeptisch ich
lese die daten auch etwas anders
ich denke nach wie vor dass die das dass
die politische gemeinschaften die wir in
europa haben dass die in erster linie
nationale gemeinschaften sind das heißt
also wenn wenn wenn wir leute fragen wie
sie sich selber sehen ja dann sind das
zehn prozent der europäer ungefähr die
sagen ich fühle mich entweder
ausschließlich europäisch oder ich fühle
mich in erster linie europäisch und dann
erst in zweiter linie national die weit
überwiegende zahl aller bürgerinnen und
bürger fühlt sich entweder
ausschließlich der eigenen nation
zugehörig oder europäisch erst in
zweiter linie politische gemeinschaften
sind auch in erster linie national
politisch strukturiert hat die parteien
die wir heute haben sind nationale
parteien
obwohl die europawahlen wichtiger werden
spielen spielen nationale themen
nationale kandidaten
eine eine wesentlich größere rolle hier
und auch die auch die öffentlichkeiten
sind natürlich nach wie vor national
yaman man liest nationalen zeitungen
schaut nationale fernsehen die leute von
denen sie sprechen dass es seine eine
eine kleine europäische kulturelle elite
die gibt es natürlich und ist auch
wichtig dass wir sie haben
aber man darf sich nicht dem irrglauben
hingeben dass das die die europäer
repräsentiert das ist eine eine eine
avantgarde sein nicht aber für für
politische transformation und braucht
man eben mehr
vielleicht kann dir auch noch den
französischen philosophen alain
finkielkraut ins boot nehmen
der sagt ganz klar es gibt keine post
nationale demokratie denn wir werden
nicht als weltbürger geboren
ja das stimmt und deswegen rede ich auch
gar nicht von der post nationalen
demokratie ich rede auch nicht von
supranationalen strukturen ich finde
tatsächlich das ist ein ganz neues
vokabular und das schon richten nicht
die bürger an
deswegen habe ich ja bewusst den begriff
europäische republik gewählt republik
ist ja was ganz anderes
die republik ist warm sie kümmert sich
die bürger verstehen intuitiv sie sind
der souverän
sie verstehen aber auch intuitiv dass
niemand heimat und identität verliert in
einer republik man muss unterscheiden
zwischen wo ist meine heimat und was ist
der politische überbau ja und ich bin
trotzdem noch mal hier zu diesen zahn
zog ja es gibt wahnsinnig viele zahlen
die wir haben wir haben im großen und
ganzen riesen daten salat ja aber zu
sagen dass das eine eliten geschichte
ist das stimmt einfach nicht sie haben
auch auf dem flachen land in je allen
möglichen dürfen in europa die leute
sind a priori europäisch das was die
leute wollen ist ein starkes europa in
der welt dass ihnen ihre identität nicht
weg nimmt die identität aber ist nicht
die nationale gucken sie mal nach
frankreich an die kursen und die
bretonen die haben kulturell wirklich
echt wenig zusammen mit einander zu tun
was die dateien ist die rechtsgleichheit
und was heißt europäische republik das
heißt ja nicht dass ich irgendwie im die
identität wegnehmen oder ein superstart
mache oder was supranationales mache
sondern das heißt eigentlich nur ein
zustand in europa in dem einst gilt was
für eine demokratie fundamental ist
nämlich der allgemeine politische
gleichheitsgrundsatz für alle
europäischen bürgerinnen und bürger das
ist was ganz anderes und sie sagen aber
trotzdem der nationalstaat den würde man
ablösen durch regionen
man hätte dann region
die gegen die aus kleinen dann
funktionieren würde
es wäre meine frage wie definieren sie
denn diese regionen werden sie den
bevölkerungs größen entlang gehen oder
den ethnien den kulturen den
sprachregionen definiert diese region
also wir sind in der schweiz der
niedergang war ja ein bekannter
schweizer dazu viele arbeiten gemacht
hat aber was ich gerne sagen würde wir
müssen uns darauf einigen wie wir
nationen definieren nation und
nationalstaat ja und alle modernen
definitionen von nation anthony giddens
oder stein rockern oder wählen sie auch
immer in die debatte werfen nach film
aus definieren nation nicht über
identität und über heimat sondern nation
ist im grunde der solidar verbannte wo
sie sind soll heißen sie sind züricher
aus basel oder aus bern das ist ihre
identität oder vielleicht auch so machen
die politikwissenschaft und das ist ja
die diskussion abermals auch
verfassungspatriotismus wir haben uns
hier zusammen gerade sagen wir gehören
zusammen
wir brauchen nicht so ein dickes
identitaire aufgeladenes heimatgefühl
stimmt aber wahrscheinlich aber es gibt
viele leute wollen das ja aber wir rufen
sie es geht gar nicht um
verfassungspatriotismus es geht um
solidarität wo ist die struktur die
ihnen im netz gucken sich an belgien zum
beispiel belgische nation ja die gibt es
ja eigentlich gar nicht die alge flammen
sagen wir sind für flammen
die wallonen sagen wir sind verloren die
identität ist also flämisch oder
wallonisch ja was hält die beiden
zusammen die belgische
sozialversicherung ja das ist im grunde
die nation das heißt die inflation ist
der solidar verband auf dem man sich
einigen kann und in der hinsicht sage
ich ja nur europa müsste als solidar
verband die nation werden und jeder
behält seine heimat das ist in der
analyse ist es völlig richtig ja also
was die was die nation heutzutage
ausmacht ist natürlich in erster linie
dieser solidar verband stein rockern
andere sagen natürlich auch es geht auch
sehr stark über über über sprache über
kulturelle homogenisierung also
staatsgründung hat auch die
erfolgreichen staatsgründung haben etwas
zu tun mit homogenen kulturen das haben
natürlich in europa überhaupt nicht und
genau diese dieser diese
wohlfahrtsstaatlichen dimension das ist
ja da das hat der bereich in dem europa
sich haben sich haben sich am schwersten
tut ja
und man muss einfach sehen europa ist
was was das was das wohlstandsgefälle
angeht viel heterogener als jedes andere
politische gebilde was wir auf der auf
der welt haben luxemburger sind 13 mal
so reich wie bulgaren diese unterschiede
hat man nicht in der schweiz die hat man
nicht in den innen in den usa in indien
haben sich ein in ägypten haben sie aber
das sind staatsgründung die natürlich
nicht von unten gewachsen sind her
sondern die kolonial geschaffen worden
sind
und ich sehe momentan eben keinen weg
die solidaritäts gefühle solidaritäts
empfindungen der menschen die sind eben
doch sehr im nationalen rahmen und wenn
man wenn man sich wenn man sich das
anschaut wie groß ist die bereitschaft
ja abzugeben und europäisch zu teilen
hat das da sieht man einfach die starken
grenzen ja also das heißt es gibt es
gibt zwischen reichen und armen in
schweden eine viel engere bindung als
zwischen den armen in schweden und den
armen in griechenland da bin ich beinahe
dass wir uns nicht falsch verstehen ja
also in der halle in der analyse bin ich
voll bei hamm schimmelpfennig ja das was
ich nur sage ist genau daran wird europa
scheitert weil wenn europa sozusagen es
nicht schafft sich als nation zu
verstehen im sinne eines solidar
verbandes jaaa dann sind wir und dann
sind wir mitten in der aktuellen
politischen krise in einem zustand der
europäischen union wo wir im grunde
staaten gegen staaten und damit bürger
gegen bürger stellen das heißt innerhalb
der elfer klose juni im grunde eine
ökonomische konkurrenz zwischen bürgern
machen das können wir machen das ist für
die wirtschaft sehr gut für die bürger
eher nicht und deswegen sind gehörlos
ist ein bürgerkrieg
deswegen schauen wir spaltung prozesse
in einzelnen gesellschaften ja weil wenn
sie zum beispiel sagen wir wollen einen
elfer klose jungen ein politisches
projekt ja also ich will nur sagen es
gibt wir haben ein zielkonflikt ja
entweder wollen wir ein politisches
projekt europa und demokratie in europa
dann müssen die bürger gleichgestellt
seien vor dem recht das ist die
bedingung einer demokratie oder wir
verstehen die eu als standortwettbewerb
von einzelnen ländern
dann spielen wir bürger gegen bürger aus
das können wir machen das ist für die
wirtschaft
weil sie so gucken sie jetzt mal auf die
wirtschaftsbeziehung von deutschland zu
ungarn ja und die deutsche wirtschaft
macht aus ungarn in anführungsstrichen
ein deutsches industrie protektorat ja
weil da einfach die löhne billiger sind
die steuern billiger sind usw
das ist wunderbar für die deutsche
wirtschaft für die ungarn ist es nicht
gut und dann wundern wir uns warum wir
populismus haben ich will nur sagen wir
haben ich will das noch analysieren wir
haben ein zielkonflikt zwischen einer
ever closer junien deren bedingungen es
wäre wenn wir eine demokratie schaffen
wollten dass die bürger rechtsgleichheit
genießen
wenn wir das nicht machen können wir
sagen schick und schön haben wir die eu
die eu macht standortwettbewerb race to
the bottom übersteuern berger the
neighbour lohndumping von deutschland
und das können wir alles machen es ist
gut vor allen dingen für die deutschen
wir haben aber effekte in den
nachbarländern und diese effekte führen
im politischen und sozialen prozesse
populismus den wir dann beklagen
das ist eigentlich nur mal die analyse
der analyse stimme ich zu aber ich finde
die schlussfolgerung dass daran europa
scheitert die geht es aus meiner sicht
in die irre weil es davon abhängt wie
man europa definiert und welches europa
man als zielvorstellung hat natürlich
daran würde ein europa als eine eine
große enge politische gemeinschaft
scheitern aber das aus meiner sicht ist
die schlussfolgerung europa dann so zu
konstruieren dass ist mit den nationalen
solidargemeinschaften kompatibel bleibt
also ein europa zu konstruieren dass
diese nationalen solidargemeinschaften
nicht aushöhlt sondern sondern stärkt
und wenn sie sagen dass die dass die
dass die bürger europa wollen dann ist
das sicherlich richtig aber wir müssen
auch fragen welches europa sie wollen
ich glaube es ist nach wie vor so dass
sie ein europa wollen das problem
lösungen dient die der nationalstaat
wegen seiner kleinräumigkeit nicht mehr
nicht mehr liefern kann ist
ich glaube die die vorstellung ist
europa soll probleme lösen
es ist nicht unbedingt die vorstellung
wir wollen unsere nationalstaaten
überwinden und in einem europäischen
gebilde aufgehen ich glaube dass das
sind zwei unterschiedliche konzepte die
dann eben auch mit diesen
unterschiedlichen vorstellungen
partikel seien müssen um da sie dich
gerne mal ansetzen weil er bei der
problemlösung weil man vielleicht auch
noch einfach überlegen kann die würde
man denn überhaupt die länder den
aktionen ins boot holen wollen die nicht
teil sind die da nicht mitmachen wollen
oder sogar aussteigen wollen
wie großbritannien und es ist gerade
eine neue studie erschienen die
bertelsmann-studie die hat aufgezeigt
dass die schweiz die ja teil ist des
eu-binnenmarktes die absolute gewinnerin
ist dieses eu binnenmarkt also das heißt
die schweiz macht nicht mit bei der eu
samt aber ab dh es stellt sich ja dann
schon die frage warum eigentlich sollte
man damit machen müssen ein anderes
beispiel ist das hier die schweiz nicht
mitglied der eu kann aber frisch
fröhlich durch die gegend reisen wegen
schengen dublin ist hier also sozusagen
vom europäischen strahlenkranz umrahmt
wir müssen keine papiere zeitung wir
haben bilaterale verträge oder sie
erwähnen selber das buch denn das
beispiel dänemark und schweden nicht
teil der eurozone florieren aber also
meine frage ist was ist eigentlich der
grund damit zu machen wenn es auch ohne
gibt na ja also es geht hier nicht ohne
also ich bin ja ich bin ja bei ihnen und
bei herrn schimmelpfennig ja also man
kann natürlich sagen wir machen da alle
mit und wir sahen ab beendete day können
nicht alle nur absahnen und deshalb
niemand einen preis der punkt ist nur
dass der preis unsichtbar ist und wir
bezahlen den preis gerade mit dem akuten
verfall von rechtsstaatlichkeit
demokratie populismus und nationalismus
in europa weil irgendwo hin verschiebt
sich ja die energie derjenigen die den
preis dafür bezahlen
es kann nicht jeder absahnen einer muss
die sahne hören ja
und in dem moment wo wir das nicht
demokratisch verhandeln wer hier absahnt
und weil wir nämlich keine gemeinsamen
demokratischen strukturen haben und
deswegen auch von denjenigen die
absahnen anführungsstriche nicht mehr
sozusagen das abschöpfen und wieder in
die distribution für die gesellschaft
geben haben wir ein politisches problem
das einzige worauf ich hinaus will ist
dass wir eine verlagerung von kosten
haben und im moment gibt es halt
sozusagen im system
andere elemente die einfach den preis
dafür bezahlen dass einige absagen
und da würden jetzt wahrscheinlich
einige euro skeptiker sagen die
entschuldigung da sind die haut zu weit
gegangen
die haben das zu weit getrieben mit
dieser eu jetzt haben sie probleme die
so sollten wir die aus baden
ja aber ich finde auch dass das fleming
als als absahnen etwas zu zu einseitig
ja also ich denke man kann das ganze
auch positiver formulieren
nämlich dass diese europäische union ein
offenes projekt ist ja dass sie sich
zusammensetzt aus ganz unterschiedlichen
politischen projekten aus der
währungsunion aus aus dem raum des
freien reisens im schengenraum und dass
das staaten staatsvölker selbst
entscheiden können ja wo sie mitmachen
und wo sie lieber nicht mitmachen wollen
wenn man mitmachen will dann heißt es
natürlich auch dass man institutionelle
verpflichtungen eingeht das geht
manchmal ein bisschen auch in der
schweizer diskussion verloren ja das
heißt natürlich der der preis dafür dass
man durch den durch die teilnahme an
binnenmarkt so viel gewinnt ist
natürlich dass man sich den regeln
dieses binnenmarktes auch unterwerfen
muss wie man eben nicht selber nicht
selber mitschreiben kann ja aber dieses
dieses geben und nehmen bei dem aber
jeder jeder staat jedes jedes staatsvolk
in europa selber entscheiden kann wie
weit man gehen will ich glaube das ist
eine form die eben mit dieser
verankerung in nationalen politischen
gemeinschaften höchst kompatibel ist und
außerdem sind in dem sinne auch dieser
europäischen union eigentlich sehr gut
entspricht es ist aber viel zu staatlich
gedacht weil sie denken vom staat her
und neben national stand und nicht von
der gesellschaft her ich mache es mal
ganz anders wir denkmal von der
gesellschaft her um das plädoyer dafür
zu machen dass sie nicht dauerhaft das
wäre meine these ein prozess der
sozioökonomischen vergesellschaftung
praktisch machen können und das machen
wir ja im binnenmarkt und mit dem euro
und das sagt wurzeln wissen ohne naja
ich technik noch formal ganz konkret wir
haben 20 millionen rumänen davon haben
fünf millionen rumänen in der letzten
dekade rumänien verlassen warum sie sind
eine junge frau gegen medizin studieren
in bukarest und dann haben sie sind sie
fertig dann haben sie ein großes
interesse nach lyon oder barcelona oder
berlin zu gehen weil sie das vierfache
verdienen jetzt bildet rumänien mit
einer staatlichen universität die von
staatlichen rumänischen
gefördert wird ganz viele tolle ärzte
aus die alle das land verlassen das ist
ein prozent und das ist alles gut für
die orden ich kritisiere die leute nicht
ich würde das auch wahrscheinlich machen
ja sie haben damit aber ein prozess der
vergesellschaftung der einfach die leute
mischt und zwar jenseits von
staatlichkeit ja
und trotzdem ist dann einfach nicht klar
wer finanziert denn jetzt eigentlich die
rumänische universität und wo gehen
sozusagen die leistungen dieser also
früher war es einfach mal so der stadt
rumänien finanziert seine ärzte und hat
dann auch ärzte jetzt finanziert der
ärzte und hat kein ärzte ja und das sind
prozesse der vergesellschaftung wo man
sagen müsste am ende des tages bilden
wir das in einer politischen demokratie
europa ab um diese sache gemeinsam zu
entscheiden und das nenne ich einen
prozess der sozioökonomischen
verflechtung der im grunde nach
gemeinsamer politischer repräsentanz
schreien wird in zukunft ja und dass wir
das gerade schmerzhaft erleben und
diskutieren verweist genau auf die
europawahl was wird denn diskutiert in
österreich wo ich gerade unterrichtet
wird diskutiert ob ein
nochmal der rumänen ende ein bulgare der
in wien arbeitet kindergeld bekommt für
seine kinder die noch in sofia sind
natürlich kriegt der kindergeld weil er
einfach eu bürger ist das wird aber
diskutiert und strittig gestellt und
damit meine ich ja nur dass wir eine
diskrepanz haben zwischen dem prozess
der vergesellschaftung der bürger die
noch nicht gemeinsam in der britischen
regierung stück weit auch der prozess
der globalisierung der voranschreitet
und darauf ein stück weit der man muss
aufpassen dass man diese entwicklungen
die sie richtig beschreiben ja nicht nur
auf die europäische union zu erkennen
kann
wir haben ja die gleichen spaltungen in
ländern die außerhalb wir haben die
gleichen spaltungen in den usa das heißt
also durch die durch die globalisierung
durch die schaffung von von von trans
von starken transnationalen offenen
märkten ja werden wird eben dieser
dieser spaltpilz in die in die
gesellschaft getragen das ist natürlich
nicht nur wirtschaftlich das ist auch
kulturell
die meisten dieser dieser die der
großteil dieser spaltung lässt sich sehr
gut auf auf bildung zurückführen bildung
ist eigentlich der neue maßstab dafür
wie sich diese diese gesellschaften
aufspalten weil sich über bildung
natürlich chancen an der markt teilhabe
ergeben aber auch kulturelle offenheit
ja und diejenigen die
die in diesem bildungswettbewerb eben
benachteiligt sind ja die sehen sich als
verlierer dieser entwicklung und das
sehen wir in der europäischen union aber
natürlich auch außerhalb das hat
insgesamt genauso viel mit
globalisierung zu tun wie mit
europäischer integration er nicht ganz
weil wir haben natürlich in der eu genau
die strukturen nämlich wären schon mal
das gleiche geld das ist natürlich ein
treiber für vergesellschaftung ja
jenseits von globalisierung
ich finde auch diese versetzen
gesellschaft und prozesse finde ich ein
ganz ganz spannende beobachtung und ich
würde auch sagen ja die entwicklung ist
offen ja die vergesellschaftung geht
weiter in diesem sinne ich bin auch
niemand jetzt den den staat an sich
verherrlichen will ich sage nur im
augenblick ist es eben so
die das dass die dass die menschen sich
dem start zugehörig fühlen dort
verankert sind und dass man eben
behutsam sein muss ja und das ist ja
auch interessant dass man merkt man kann
nicht einfach über die ängste über die
geschichte von ländern hinweg gehen über
die empfindlichkeiten die auch
historisch gewachsen sind und ein gutes
beispiel schreibt mir da der black sea
zu sein und da wiederum der sogenannte
backstop also die frage wie man
eigentlich die künftige eu außengrenze
die das britische nordirland von irland
trennen soll wie man die ausgestatten
soll
wir waren letztes jahr in irland
anlässlich des zwanzigsten jahrestages
der des karfreitagsabkommens das
bauhausjahr frieden gebracht hat in
diese einstige unruheprovinz
so friedlich die natur hier scheint ihr
land ist bis heute eine geteilte insel
um mit dem break sieht stellt sich die
frage ob die weiche grenze eine harte
grenze wird nämlich eine zwischen europa
und großbritannien
denn seit 1921 ist diese insel geteilt
drei viertel der insel gehören zur
republik irland ein viertel gehört zu
großbritannien um die diesen einem
viertel tote bis vor 20 jahren ein
blutiger bürgerkrieg der über 3.500
todesopfer forderte
[Musik]
reportagen nicht regelmäßig aber hier
und da und da sind wir nach irland
gegangen und wir haben damit menschen
gesprochen vor ort und gefragt was
bewegt sie und die angst ist natürlich
dass der bürgerkrieg zurückkehren könnte
zeigt das nicht ein stück weit auch das
rad der geschichte können wir einfach
auch gar nicht zurückdrehen also erstmal
ist ja schon wieder zurück ja diese
journalistin jeder erschossen wurde wann
war das vor sechs wochen oder so also
wir sehen ja dass wert und das hat mir
einfach 20 jahren nicht mehr
stattgefunden
das heißt ich habe auch sehr viele
irische freunde die zutiefst besorgt
sind dass wir eben keine lösung also
keine plausible lösung finden können für
diese bags stop regelung ja weil
entweder und das verführt mich wieder
auf meine vergesellschaftung ja sie
können grenzen nicht schließen für
menschen aber öffnen für güter darum
geht es ja in letzter konsequenz ja also
die frage ist die ok also dass
großbritannien will ja noch irgendwie
binnenmarkt zur union
die wollen einfach noch frischen salat
bekommen und nicht dass da irgendwie die
ganze laster in insterburg stehen und
und die produkte da nicht noch die insel
kommen ja aber eine grenze ist eine
grenze ist eine grenze die machen sie zu
oder auf aber jedenfalls nicht nur auf
für güter und so für menschen und darum
geht es ja und das ist ganz zentral für
diese nordirland frage und daran hängt
eigentlich das gesamte konzept der eu
nämlich nur wirtschaft ist nicht das ist
ja gerade gleich sei aber auch dass
werden das dann noch ihren konflikt uns
nochmal zurück führt auf die ursprünge
ja dieser dieser europäischen idee ja
nämlich dass es am anfang natürlich sehr
stark als friedensprojekt gedacht war
und ich glaube auch die die starke
solidarität ja die der die der rest der
eu in diesem fall mit irland zeigt was
ja letztlich ein kleinere mitgliedsstaat
ist ja der aber jetzt führt in diesem
budget verhandlungen zu einer enormen
bedeutung geworden ist es zeigt eben wie
man sich hinter diesem hinter diesem
gedanken ja dass durch die europäische
union eben im frieden geschaffen wird
und grenzen überwunden werden wie wie
stark dieser gedanke nach wie vor ist
ich fand interessant in diesem kontext
auch noch mal darüber nachzudenken was
wolfgang streeck mal gesagt hat ein
deutscher ein politikwissenschaftler
er hat gesagt nationen ihre staaten das
seien soziale konstruktion so würde es
immer erzählt aber das wiederum wieder
halt nicht heißen dass man sie einfach
dekonstruieren kann
naja da befindet sich strikt an bester
gesellschaft von keine ahnung sämtliche
theorien der nation jannis trennung
nation ist ein tägliches gebet marcel
mauss nation ist die solidar union die
wir uns begeben oder wie engagierte
gemeinschaft ist das nation nichts
anderes ist als die idee also die nation
ist die idee die man dann wenn man die
idee wirklich materialisiert dass damit
habe ich andere fangen max weber wenn
man die idee wirklich materialisiert
dann baut man halt ein staat zusammen
und dann die erinnerung an den gemeinsam
und stadtbau schmiedet sozusagen
generationen gucken sich an was in
israel was reinkommt man kann es nicht
einfach dekonstruieren bloß weil es
konstruiert ist kann man es nicht
einfach das konstruieren und das ist ja
auch die schwierigkeit jetzt in diesem
land dass man sich daran sieht man hat
nämlich und man kann nicht einfach zur
isla wir es erst alles de konstruiert
worden ja also das also das müssen wir
jetzt mal ganz agnostisch natürlich mit
kriegen also die die zäsur zwischen der
einen dem der übergang von einer
staatsform in die andere ist immer mit
sie suchen verbunden ja ich bin
bundesrepublik bin und ich bin deutscher
bürgerinnen ja wir waren heiliges reich
deutscher nation sind den deutschen bund
ins deutsche reich nach weimar zu hitler
kleines deutschland großes deutschland
wir haben sieben zäsuren in 200 jahren
das heißt die staatsform hat sich immer
geändert und wird sich immer ändern ja
wer irgendwo noch vor 20 jahren gab es
in tschechien slowakei wollte eine
tschechische republik slowakische
republik vorgestern gab es kein kosovo
jetzt einmal kosovo vielleicht haben am
morgen katalonische nation übermorgen
unabhängiges schottland weil die wieder
reinholen also das hat sich doch immer
geändert
natürlich kann man das dekonstruieren es
ist alles im alles im fluss natürlicher
wenn man sich das historisch betrachtet
die nationen gab es nicht immer aber
muss man auch sehen dass die nationen
sehr starke institutionen geschaffen
haben um sich sein
um sich zu reproduzieren ja das geht
immer das geht über schulen
universitäten
es geht über nationalsprachen ja und
dass das wieder zu entwirren und
aufzulösen das ist das ist natürlich ein
langsamer prozess der lässt sich auch
nicht politisch der lässt sich auch
nicht politisch steuern in dem sinne und
und hier ist natürlich auch die
europäische union einfach schwach ja
also die hat die hat eben nicht diese
institutionen um die identität der
unionsbürger zu formen ja es gibt eben
es gibt eben keine einheitliche sprache
es gibt keine zentralen
bildungsinstitutionen und da werde ich
diesen punkte die ich gern noch einmal
aufnehmen dass einiges kostet die frage
wie agieren wir politisch welche
institutionen brauchen ihres andere ist
wie kriegen wir ein gemeinschaftsgefühl
hin
also ja ganz richtig gesagt haben viele
fügen sich ja schon als europäer aber ja
nicht alle viele länder sind gespalten
also wir können auch noch einmal das
riesaer zitieren die mantramäßig immer
sagt das britische volk hat entschieden
das britische volk hat entschieden aber
48 prozent haben dagegen den shiraz
schottland worte danach in nordirland
wollten nicht austreten und in diesem
zusammenhang würde ich gerne eher
auffällt brooks nahm noch einbringen
einer der spitzenkandidaten jetzt in
diesen euro bei europaparlamentswahlen
ein franzose hinten auf dem klappentext
steht wir haben verlernt uns als
zivilgesellschaft mit einer gemeinsamen
verantwortung zu begreifen um eine frage
wäre
ist es nicht vielmehr das problem dass
wir es gar nie waren oder uns nie so
verstanden haben oder noch nicht
hinreichend verstehen nein aber um bei
den zitat zu bleiben dass ich glaube ich
bin wieder bei max weber ja es gab es
situationen in der geschichte wo sich
eine politische gemeinschaft als
kollektiv verstanden hat und die haben
sich aufgemacht um was zu tun ein staat
zu gründen also tun wir doch nicht so
als wenn deutschland vom himmel gefallen
wäre ja wir hatten das haben wir hatten
fichte 1806 rede an die deutsche nation
da gab es die noch nicht ja dann gab es
das hambacher fest am einige sagt auch
was der fichte sagt ist doch gut machen
wir mal das hambacher fest und fordern
wir mal die deutsche formation 15 jahre
später gab es die paulskirche da wurde
die deutsche nation konstitution
amüsiert und weitere 30 jahre später gab
es die gemeinsame sozialversicherung für
die deutschen das hat alles 100 jahre
gedauert war ungefähr dann im
19 jahrhundert oder ende des 19
jahrhunderts abgeschlossen heute denken
wir deutschlands vom himmel gefallen und
war immer da wo es eher rugby haben wir
haben verlernt uns als die viel
gesellschaft zu verstehen die kriegen
die es dann hin dass wir uns wieder aus
zivilgesellschaft es passierte reißen
jetzt passiert sein also mein argument
wäre das was der glücks mann beschreibt
oder meine these wäre dass wir als
europäer genau in diesem prozess hin
stefan zweig sagt ja immer die
zeitgenossenschaft kann nicht verstehen
und welchem historischen prozess sie
sich befindet meine analyse wäre wir
sehen das noch nicht aber vielleicht das
wäre ja nur meine these sind wir genau
in dem prozess den glücks man möchte
dass wir nämlich als europäischer bürger
inzwischen dastehen und sagen wir wollen
doch ein pass vielleicht wollen wir ein
staat vielleicht machen wir uns auf
vielleicht kapieren wir diesen prozess
der vergesellschaftung und müssen den
jetzt nach konstitution analysieren
ich sehe es eher über die über die
parteien ja und die und das
parteiensystem also hier sehen wir eine
eine sehr starke politische
transformation worunter europa lange
zeit gelitten hat ist dass die fragen
wie wollen wir europa gestalten welches
europa wollen wir dass die nicht in
parteien system abgebildet waren
das ist das sehen wir natürlich auch zum
beispiel in großbritannien wo die frage
wie hältst du es mit europa mitten durch
die großen parteien geht und die daran
zerbrechen ja was wir jetzt sehen ist
eine ist eine transformation dieses
parteiensystems das eben von dem alten
links-rechts-schema weg geht und genau
die frage ja wie hältst du es mit der
offenheit deiner staatlichen grenzen die
bibel wie sehr bist du bereit politische
kompetenzen auf die europäische ebene zu
verlagern oder wie wir wie viel willst
du im nationalstaat behalten wie viele
ausländer sollten dem land leben das
wird zur neuen achse und das ist wichtig
für europa weil jetzt auf einmal die
konflikte die in europa tatsächlich die
zentrale rolle spielen auch von den
parteien abgebildet werden viele sagen
das ist ein das ist ein negatives
zeichen für europa ich sehe das genau
als eine notwendige transformation weil
dadurch europa so politisiert wird das
ist tatsächlich zum gegenstand der
politischen auseinandersetzungen wird
wir sind mit einigen diskussionen wir
sind aber auch am ende unseres gesprächs
ich würde gerne noch erinnern zum
schluss 19 46 hat winston churchill er
in zürich seine rege an die akademische
jugend
universität zürich gehalten und er hat
diesen berühmten satz gesagt darum sage
ich ihnen lassen sie europa entstehen
ich denke seinen aufruf ist aktueller
denn je allerdings auch ungewisser denn
je wie er genau geführt werden muss ich
danke ihm ganz herzlich für dieses
gespräch frau gero herrschen wenn ich
danke dass sie hierher gekommen sind
nächsten sonntag haben wir einen
literaturnobelpreisträger zu gast mario
vargas llosa
wolfram berger spricht mit ihm über das
wesen der freiheit jetzt gleich folgt
hier das abstimmungs studio nicht europa
sondern zu unseren eidgenössischen und
kantonalen vorlagen eine gute woche
bis bald
[Musik]